do you ever feel like you're living the
groundhog day of mornings wake up snooze
buttons scroll through social media
rinse and repeat if you're feeling like
your mornings are a chaotic mess then
it's time to shake things up and get on
track for a productive and successful
day in this episode we'll reveal some of
the most effective morning habits that
will supercharge your productivity and
help you start off your day right
whether you're a morning person or not
these habits will help you maximize your
energy and focus and set you on a path
to success from simple tips like getting
enough sleep and making your bed to more
advanced practices like meditation
optimizing cognition and managing a
calendar will share actionable insights
and strategies that will transform your
morning routine from chaos to Clarity if
you're ready to ditch the snooze button
and start living your best mornings this
episode is for you so pour yourself a
cup of coffee or tea and get ready to
learn how to create a morning routine
that sets you up for a successful day
Joy
okay let's take it off with rule number
one establish a powerful morning routine
with Tom bilyu morning routines are one
of the most important things that you
can create in your life and the reason
is when you start the day if you get
early momentum going the rest of the day
is often going to follow in that it's an
idea called entropy everything moves
towards chaos and the only way to combat
that is to put energy into the system
you are not going to wake up and
randomly have a good day you're going to
have to structure your day in a way that
sets you up to overcome all of the
entropy all of that chaos all of the
thousand things going to come at you in
a on a daily basis that are going to
knock you off course and the easiest way
to do that is to have a routine that you
follow every morning so you don't have
to think about it you don't have to
reinvent the wheel you don't have to
wonder or think about what you should be
doing it's just right there it is baked
into the routine so by doing that now
you can actually accomplish the most
important things first so the thing to
doing your morning routine well is is to
optimize for what Tim Ferriss refers to
as the lead Domino what's the thing that
if I did this it's going to make
everything else easier down the road so
number one a morning routine actually
starts the night before you want to get
plenty of sleep why because that's going
to optimize your your cognition the next
thing you want to do is either meditate
or work out typically I will work out
first the reason that I work out is
because it optimizes your cognition so
that everything else is going to get
easier it also dramatically impacts your
energy levels talk about two things that
are incredible lead dominoes if I'm
getting sleep and optimizing my
cognition if I'm working out and
optimizing my cognition and I'm making
sure that I have the energy levels that
I need to get things done now I'm really
making sure that everything that I do
after that is easier the next thing that
I do is meditate why because it
optimizes your cognition you want to
make sure that you're getting all of
your background radiation the stress the
anxiety you want to get that as close to
zero as you can that way you can think
clearly you get into what I call a call
home and creative state so the areas of
your brain that don't often communicate
are able to communicate get better ideas
that way again lead Domino improving
your cognition lowering your stress
levels making sure that you're centered
and that you've got that energy to move
forward then I'm going to go down my
list of important things I make that
list the day before so I know exactly
what I should be doing at any one time
and again it's a lead Domino strategy
what the first thing that I'm going to
do is going to be the thing that makes
everything else on my list easier I'm
going to do everything that I can do on
the most important thing by the way they
should always be rank ordered there is
no such thing as a tie there is a number
one a number two a number three and
number four so on and so forth there's
not two number ones there's not two
number twos there was a one two three
four five so on and so forth I do
everything that I can do on number one
once that's now where I'm waiting for
something else or you know I just have
to let it bake whatever then I'm going
to move on to number two I'm gonna do
everything I can on number two then I'm
going to move on to number three do you
set your day up like that and you're not
checking your phone and you're not
responding to other people because
that's letting them control your
schedule and what are the odds that
somebody other than you knows better
what you should be doing to make your
goals come true than you the answer
should be zero because if somebody else
knows better than you we already have a
problem it means that somebody else is
paying more attention to your own life
than you are that would be problematic
get that morning routine down get that
momentum going do the lead Domino
strategy make sure you're optimizing for
energy and cognition rule number two is
make your bag with William mcraven every
morning in Seal training my instructors
who at the time were all Vietnam
veterans
would show up in my Barracks room
and the first thing they do is inspect
my bed if you did it right
the corners would be square the covers
would be pulled tight the pillow
centered just under the headboard and
the extra blanket folded neatly at the
foot of the rack
it was a simple task
mundane at best but every morning we
were required to make our bed to
perfection
it seemed a little ridiculous at the
time particularly in light of the fact
that we were aspiring to be real
Warriors tough battle hardened seals
but the wisdom of this simple act has
been proven to me many times over
if you make your bed every morning
you will have accomplished the first
task of the day
it will give you a small sense of pride
and it will encourage you to do another
task and another and another and by the
end of the day that one task completed
will have turned into many tasks
completed making your bed will also
reinforce the fact
that the little things in life matter
if you can't do the little things right
you'll never be able to do the big
things right
and if by chance you have a miserable
day
you will come home to a bed that is made
that you made
and a made bed gives you encouragement
that tomorrow will be better
so if you want to change the world
start off by making your bed rule number
three is get quality sleep with Andrew
huberman I certainly believe that our
state of mind and body at any point in
time is strongly dictated by our state
of mind and body
in the hours and days prior to that and
on the one hand people are going to hear
that and say well duh you know if you're
sleep deprived you're going to feel like
garbage and if you're well rested you'll
feel great
that's kind of the top Contour of it but
when one looks at the Neuroscience for
instance of sleep
you start to realize that you know the
amount of rapid eye movement sleep that
you're going to get in any 90-minute
bout of sleep because your sleep is
broken up into these 90 minute segments
more or less
is strongly dictated by
the ratio of slow wave sleep AKA deep
sleep and rapid eye movement sleep that
you had in the previous 90 minute bout
and then when you start to look at the
research in terms of waking States you
start to find that your ability to be
focused say for about to work in the
morning or the afternoon or a creative
brainstorm session or
I don't know to maybe drill into some
personal issue that you're dealing with
during therapy or just on a walk or
while journaling
is not a square wave function you know
none of us should sit down and expect
ourselves to just drop into that state
much of our ability to move into that
state effectively whatever effective
means right whatever the target
or goal of that
out as I'm calling it is is going to be
dictated by what happened in the
previous
moments and hours
and so
when I zoom out from that what I've
doubled down on is this idea that
they're just a core set of foundational
things that we have to re-up every 24
hours you know I think thanks to the
incredibly hard work of Dr Matt Walker
at Berkeley right the Sleep Diplomat on
Twitter right it's such a great name
because it's so appropriate I mean a
decade ago or so you know it was like
I'll sleep when I'm dead that was the
dominant mentality out there and yeah
sleep's great but you know getting stuff
done is more important I mean Matt has
really impressed on everybody that our
mental health our physical health and
our ability to perform is so strongly
dependent on our ability to get quality
sleep maybe not every night of our life
right I mean we have to be realistic but
that sleep is vital so a hat tip is
insufficient
so sleep is critical in the absence of
quality sleep over two or three days
you're just gonna fall to pieces in the
presence of quality sufficient sleepover
two or three days You're Gonna function
in an amazing level
there's a gain of function and a loss of
function there it's not just if you
sleep poorly you function less well you
sleep better you function much better so
sleep I would say is at the top of the
list
also to make sure you're actually taking
action after watching this video I've
designed a special free worksheet just
for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the Lessons Learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business I'll see you
there rule number four is stop killing
time with Alex hermosi I had a young
entrepreneur reach out to me and he said
hey man I'm really struggling he said
I'm doing something that my mentor told
me to do and he told me and so he said
my whole morning routine takes me three
hours and he basically did that whole
checklist he's like I walk outside
barefoot 30 minutes so I can like Center
myself and then I do the red light sauna
and I do floating and then I do like all
this stuff right he's like and it's just
like it's killing my dad he's like by
the time I start it's like you know 11
A.M
and uh he's like because he also needs
me to sleep this amount of hours and all
this stuff and I was like dude
sometimes the work just needs doing man
like everyone I think I think a lot of
the stuff is is productive
procrastination or people think it's
productive procrastination but it's just
another form of procrastination they
feel like it's like watching TED Talks
it's like you feel like you learn
something but like you're not making
more money like you've got to make 200
dials whatever way you want to do that
go for it you know what I mean but for
me like the longer I'm putting it off
the longer I feel like I'm guilty about
not doing it rule number five is manage
your calendar with J Shetty if it's not
in the calendar it won't get done it's
not really a priority right you have to
make sure that it's in your plan it's in
your day so I'm going to show you
quickly what my calendar and schedule
look like that is my life this month as
you can see it's color coded it's
beautifully designed and as I flick
through this what you realize is that
every single day I have everything from
workout time to meal times to scheduled
off time all in my calendar what this
allows me to do is it helps me
prioritize both personal and
professional commitments and helps me
see both things in the same place if you
haven't put something in your calendar
if it's something social I promise you
you'll either forget it or you won't
plan effectively around it when I know I
have a really big podcast or a really
big interview or if I know that I have a
big deadline on a day I don't then
surround that day with other difficult
and challenging tasks sometimes I'll
start my day with the most challenging
task of the day because I feel that I
need to start with a challenge and
sometimes I'll actually put it as the
last most challenging task of the day
because actually I want to build that
momentum when you have a schedule you
get context around how you feel that way
you manage your mental health and
well-being a million times better and
you do more with less time rule number
six is organize your time with Mark
Cuban how do you do all of this I mean
honestly like your schedule between the
shark shark tank all those companies
doing like these things I mean like what
time are you waking up in the morning 6
5 36 like what's the date like give me a
day you probably should admit this but
like I'll get up at 5 36 particularly
during the school year my kids are going
to school you have three kids yeah 12 15
and 18. yeah are you involved do you see
these kids because how are you able to
do all I don't travel that much and
unless they're out doing stuff really
right now my middle daughter um Melissa
is at Camp my wife and my youngest son
Jake who's 12 are in Iceland right now
they went on a trip because while I'm
shooting Shark Tank that's when they all
know to go do their trips that's a good
idea yeah and then my oldest is on a
trip as well so with her class and so
all you know so while we're shooting
they're gone and so that's when I pack
everything in and then you do everything
yeah but otherwise you know I can do one
day trips here or one day trips there
because you know I'd rather spend time
with my family so you so you are like
you spend a lot of time with your yeah
of course yeah that's the best yeah
that's the best part of my life okay so
tell me the day give me your daily you
wake up at you said six o'clock wake up
yeah 5 36 do you know say hi to
everybody gives everybody going to
school if that's what's up and um then
do my email and typically get back in
bed do my email get through any
emergency please go back take a nap
really yeah oh yeah so wait so you do
the emails first before you do anything
else right yeah
said that a bunch of times yeah and you
know I've got an eye watch like you
right so I look at my sleep right I wear
it wisely and so I'll see how much sleep
I got you know because you don't really
you might feel okay and you don't you
know when you didn't sleep but sometimes
you don't know how much sleep you got
100 yeah exactly and so like if I got my
200 deep deep asleep right my two my two
hours rather then I'm usually pretty
good right right so wait what time do
you go to bed at night typically
anywhere from Midnight to 1 30. okay and
then you wake up around you get like
you're in bed for five six hours and
then if like if I didn't really get good
sleep okay then I get my email done go
back to sleep yeah really yeah
yeah so I get an hour like I'm not one
of these people that's just like oh I
just gotta Slug It Out whatever yeah
cause remember everybody's gotta kiss my
ass and rule number seven the last one
before some very special bonus Clips is
stop the productivity overload with
Gabby Bernstein many of us have issues
with productivity
maybe we are overly productive but we're
feeling burnt out all the time or we're
not productive at all because we don't
know where to start I found personally
being in business for myself for the
last 20 years that I have been a little
overly productive I almost did too much
and I was constantly multitasking and
making things happen and just moving so
fast that ultimately I really burnt out
and I started feeling brain fog I was
feeling disoriented I couldn't focus I
was feeling like even though I for so
many years was priding myself on the
fact that I could get so much done at
one time I actually don't think I was
being nearly as productive as I could
have been so I hit a bottom recently
with this productivity overload and I
realized that I had to change my
patterns I had to change my ways I was
then blessed I said a prayer I said I
need some help with my brain fog and I
need some help with my productivity
issue and I that day got an email from
The Dr Oz Show asking me to come on and
do a segment with this lovely author and
doctor Dr Mike Dow and me and Mike had
been in touch many years for many years
just because he had been an author we
were published by the same Publishers
and Mike had written a book about brain
fog so that day I'm like thank you
Universe you're giving me exactly what I
need I go on Dr Oz with Mike and I'm
backstage with him and I'm like listen
I'm feeling so chaotic and I'm
multitasking so much and my but I feel
like I've got brain fog and I'm
forgetting things and he looked at me
and says how much are you doing at one
time and I said oh Mike I'm doing a
million things at once I have a thousand
tabs up on my screen and he's like these
are Big Brain no-nos and they're also
productivity no-nos is what he said
because he said that the more I try to
do and the more I try to multitask the
less I'm actually getting done so he
gave me a tip that I want to share with
you that has changed everything for me
and his suggestion was to just do five
things a day to make a list of the five
most important things that I need to do
that day and not do number two until
I've completed number one and then once
I complete number one move on to number
two then on to number three and if I
don't get through all five in one day
I'll just pick up the fifth the next day
or wherever I left off I'll pick up the
next day
and to really stick to that list and not
move back and forth and not try to make
a million other things added on to that
list and just be really committed to
that five task list
I did it I started to just be very clear
about the five things I was doing in a
day I told my team I made a a list in my
base camp which is where we keep all of
our notes and I made it really clear to
myself these are the only five things
I'm doing throughout the day
as a result of making it super clear and
conscious to myself that I was only
going to do five things I have been more
productive I have created more I have
been more intuitive I have been more
inspired and I've been more creative
something that a lot of people don't
understand about procrastination is it
really has nothing to do for the most
part with being lazy if you think about
the word procrastinate right it's to put
off until tomorrow basically is the
Latin root or derivative of
procrastinate and a lot of people think
you know you procrastinate because
you're lazy and the answer is no you
don't there are really three main
reasons why you may procrastinate number
one
there are some people a few people that
procrastinate because it's an arousal
mechanism and they know they need to get
something done
but they just don't feel like doing it
right now and they wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait wait wait and actually
the energy builds up and if there's a
deadline something called Parkinson's
law kicks in which says that you will
get done what you need to get done in
the time allotted to get it done in and
so Parkinson's law basically says you
know if you wait right until that last
minute for some people it creates this
arousal and it brings out the best in
them
is that you I don't know
number two is fear when somebody has
something that needs to get done if
there is any self-doubt if there is you
know the risk of being embarrassed
ashamed ridiculed judged failing at it
then your subconscious is automatically
going to put a block on the motivation
and the motor cortex of your brain is
going to say don't do it like you know
just wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait
number three
self-image self-esteem self-worth when
there is
a project something you want to start
something you want to stop
and you don't feel like you're worthy of
it or you feel like it's not going to
measure up to what you have imagined it
to be
you're going to bump against your
self-image or self-esteem self-worth
type of stuff and this tends to create
perfectionists that in their own mind
they think that well let me wait till
it's perfect and what they're really
saying is if it's not perfect in my mind
then that's going to show how imperfect
I am and therefore I'm not good enough
I'm not worthy
Etc see how this cycle works so arousal
fear and self-esteem self-worth was
really tied to fear and so what do you
do first is become aware
which is causing you to procrastinate
and certainly by the way there's another
area here of you know things like I
don't want to make my bed you know we've
all heard that if we have kids and we've
also been that you know I don't want to
clean X Y or Z I don't want to tidy up
it's I just don't want to do it because
I don't like it or hate it and I just
don't want to do it oh well that's guess
what that's that's a valid reason not to
but let's go deal with the other three
so awareness of which reason is causing
you to procrastinate that's step one and
then step two is to say okay
if I don't take action what pattern am I
reinforcing am I reinforcing the fear am
I reinforcing the self-worth and
self-esteem that may be in question here
and is that what I really want because
if I keep reinforcing a disempowering or
negative or destructive pattern I become
more of the pattern that I actually need
to let go of
if I want to succeed more in my life
right so create some what I call our
pain frames if I continue to
procrastinate if I continue to be
perfect or try to be if I continue to
have these fears I'm going to become
more of what I don't want to become
that's a negative reinforcement pattern
now let's shift the frame to saying now
what if I just take a little bit of
action what if I take one or two little
micro easy to follow through on steps so
that I can a interrupt the disempowering
pattern and B reinforce the pattern then
I'm an action taker I have some
confidence I can create some certainty I
can move forward and I can become the
person that I want to become
one pattern keeps you stuck one pattern
creates Freedom guess what I want for
you I want freedom for you mental
Freedom emotional freedom and behavioral
Freedom so that you take inspired action
and do the things that you know you
should be and could be doing to achieve
your success I know you all have big
goals Big Dreams big aspirations just
like I do you've got Ambitions to become
an amazing person to build your career
to create contribute to give to be an
awesome human being but all of that is
impossible without great habit set up if
you don't have routine and structure set
up in a way that will keep you on track
then you'll you'll fall off and and
having new goals without new habits is
kind of like you know having a new car
without wheels you know the habits are
the wheels they're the things that make
you able to achieve the goals so you got
to have good habits but the challenge
for most people isn't that knowledge I
mean you know you need to have good
habits it's you you can't keep the Habit
going right have you ever started it the
new year you're going to get healthier
and you start that habit of working out
on a more regular basis and then it goes
away or you say you know I'm going to be
more kind and more patient and more
awesome to my partner my lover and you
start being nice for two or three days
and then on the fourth day you're a jerk
you know and you're like why what
happened I said I was gonna be nicer
it's that you didn't set up the most
important thing you needed to maintain a
habit so what's the biggest secret I've
learned in almost 20 years in this field
it's so simple but most people don't
have it it's called trigger moments
you have to set up trigger moments to
activate your habits what do I mean by
that well let's say you want to become a
better person you know you want to
become more kind more patient more
loving with people now you can just set
that intention or write that down in
your vision in your your journal or set
up on a vision board that you look at
once in a while but in day-to-day life
it's not enough you need things to
trigger you to remind you to be that
particular kind of person right it's
almost like if you could have a little
angel speaking in your ear all day long
to tell you what to do and how to be
you'd obviously become better well that
makes sense well let's use that idea
let's use that idea by setting up alarms
on our phones that trigger us to do the
very things we need to do this can be so
basic you're going to laugh and then
also tell you how I've literally taught
this to Fortune 50 CEOs and they said it
was the one thing that changed their
life the most dramatically so let's
start with this let's have a goal in
mind let's say you want to become more
present and calm throughout the day
again you could write that down on a
journal I'm going to be more present and
calm you can meditate in the morning
saying today I'm gonna be more present
and calm and you're you could you could
start out with good intentions but those
fall apart without a trigger moment set
up throughout the day to remind you that
so what if you did this what if you just
set up on your phone three alarms during
the day with a label that said
close your eyes
take 10 deep breaths in remind yourself
to be calm
so let's say you're going through your
day it's crazy right it's 10 a.m and
also Bing your phone goes off you look
down and it says close your eyes take 10
deep breaths and then again it happens
at two o'clock and again it happens at 6
p.m and again it happens at 8pm
what's gonna happen you always look at
your phone don't you it's going to go
throughout the day you're going to
forget and the funniest thing is I've
had so many people do this worldwide
we're talking about hundreds of
thousands of people I've taught to do
this hundreds of thousands and they tell
me all the time that changed everything
and you'll think once you set it up that
the next day you you'll you'll forget
about it no that alarm will go off you
forgot you set the dang alarm there it
goes off in your face you're like all
right I'm trying to be calmer and more
present close my eyes take 10 deep
breaths reground myself here we go
you can't do it once a day you have to
have moments throughout the day that
trigger you to enact the new Behavior I
know this makes sense to you but it's a
challenge for a lot of people because
they never set those things up so what
if you did it with an alarm
so for example for me on the opposite
Spectrum I don't want to just be calmer
and more present I Want More Energy
throughout the day so here's what I do
one of my big trigger moments is every
time my butt hits a chair I don't care
if I'm on a plane or I was like where
we're shooting here I I wrote a lot of
my books here I wrote the motivation
Manifesto here I wrote The Charge here
and if I'm going to write my butt hits
the chair I grab my phone I open the
timer and I set 50 minutes
now at 50 minutes the timer goes it
starts buzzing and I look at that and I
go oh that's my trigger to get energy so
I stand up I go get some water I take a
glass of water drink it down I do some
stretches and I do some exercise just
really briefly or I'll go for a walk
whatever it is but I'll do something
that usually takes just two to five
minutes then I'll sit back down I'll set
that 50 minute alarm and I'll work
and what that does is every 50 minutes
it triggers me to change how I'm
physically moving it changes my
attention so that throughout the day I'm
continually refreshed so I never have
that two three four o'clock time where
I'm like ah you know why because I've
triggered my day so that my energy is
maintained throughout the day makes
sense right this could be as simple as
let's say you want to be healthier in
your life okay let's set up some trigger
moments for you in this way let's say
every time you drop off the kids on the
way back to the house you stop at the
grocery store and get some fresh produce
that's just a trigger it's like okay did
one thing drop kids off now tied to that
triggered from that action drop kids off
is go to health food store or let's say
you want to get healthier in the morning
one of the easiest ways to help people
maintain a better exercise program is
this
set a trigger you wake up in the morning
your first action is to drink water
put your exercise shoes on it might get
dressed if you were naked just saying so
you get dressed put your shoes on you go
downstairs or you go to the gym and
that's the trigger you woke up you do
these actions nothing interrupts those
actions that's the action and you have
to have those set up one of my other
favorite trigger moments to set up is
door frame triggers what do you remember
that when you walk into a new room
to have a psychological trigger go off
in your mind that you've associated with
that door frame so let me give you an
example if I walk into my house at night
after if I've been working all day and
I'm going to walk in I'm gonna see my
lady I haven't so when I ever walk
through the doors of my house three
words repeat off immediately in my mind
because I've done it so many times
consciously I went to the door I said
the three words said three words said
the three words and I did this so many
times and now when I walk through a door
my mind automatically triggers those
three words and I remember to be those
three words so what words would you love
to have describe you as a person that
you would be happy if that was how
people described you what would those
words be have those and now set them up
in your life I teach Executives to do
this as well I have them have a door
frame trigger when they walk into their
office in the morning as soon as they
walk through that door frame they have
boom three words go through their mind
about how they want to be perceived as a
leader I have them set up another door
frame every time they walk into a
meeting into the conference room when
they walk through the doors of the
conference room they have another three
words that trigger off for them and it
just reminds them how to be so these
aren't big crazy things a lot of people
think they have to completely change
their life what would change your life
completely is setting up more trigger
moments and associations that when you
see something you do this that when this
action is taken then that happens that
when you have the opportunity to set up
alarms on your phone you set them up so
that you're interrupted in your everyday
life to remind yourself to stick to the
habits to stick to the intention you do
that enough on a continual basis you'll
find yourself in so many ways completely
rejuvenated and I promise you'll stick
to your habits even more and once you do
that you know that everything changes in
that year when I was really broken I was
really broken I was working at La
Unified School District
I was miserable
I was miserable because I wasn't living
in my dream I was just doing a j-o-b and
then one day
I said well what what do I need to do I
I need to I need to buy my freedom
that's what I need to do I need to buy
my freedom well I don't know about
buying my freedom I don't know about
buying I don't know about having money
saved up my family didn't have money
saved up my mother used to tell me oh
this money is burning my pocket so I
know two things about money is hot
and we can't keep it long
we'd always have one week where we had
all the food in the refrigerator and
then one week where we were the
refrigerator was empty
right come on come on some of you guys
know about that to this day I spend so
much money on groceries you guys oh my
God it's like I'm feeding like a family
of 10. because I'm so afraid of anybody
ever being in my house and being hungry
and so I I wrote a check to myself
Jelani was three
110 dollars
I took it to the bank
Wells Fargo
started a new account
the next check I wrote
125 dollars
and just like the first check I put in
the memo line funding my dream I wasn't
even clear what the dream was
but I knew there was something in my
belly who in this room know you got
something in your belly it's something
I'm not even clear about it I don't know
how clear you are but I wasn't clear
about it but I knew there was a calling
on my life greater than working for La
Unified School District at no disrespect
to La Unified School District it just
wasn't my destiny
I wrote another check in two weeks
146 dollars
funding my dream
now I started mailing the checks in
because I didn't want to see my balance
because I didn't want to go shopping
because I you're gonna repeat what you
learn right until you decide to not
repeat what you've learned
so I mailed the check in and I wrote
another check and I wrote another check
and every check I wrote I made sure it
was five percent more than the first
check the net the previous check I sold
my Altima I had a car note sold my auto
bought a clunker because it didn't have
a car note now I can write a bigger
check funding my dream
I moved out of my three bedroom three
bath three bath house and moved in
became a roommate with my friend who
smoked I put towels at the base of the
door so the smoke wouldn't come to the
door I was willing to be inconvenienced
are you yes I'm just saying I'm just I'm
just showing you the story I just the
charge I just gave you I stopped getting
my hair done that was when I started
going natural
I I stopped going out I I stopped going
out dancing I stopped going out to
dinners my family didn't know what was
going on they thought oh my God you know
it was La she's on drugs but she's not
losing weight so maybe not I don't know
what's going on
I kept writing bigger checks to myself
nine hundred dollars nine hundred
dollars
I mailed it to Wells Fargo funding my
dream
eleven hundred dollars
mailed it to Wells Fargo funding my
dream I still wasn't clear what the
dream was
I just knew I had one
and it was being born through me
and I needed to give it a chance
that's all I knew
you don't have to see 2 000 feet in
front of you just see 200.
and run to the 200.
you'll have to see it all
three and a half years later I'd written
a check to myself every two weeks for
three and a half years
I didn't go out for three and a half
years I didn't go dancing I didn't get
my hair done I didn't get my nails done
for three and a half years are you
willing to be inconvenience for your
conviction
I walk in to Wells Fargo three and a
half years later
and I said hi God bless you hi
my name is Lisa Nichols she was oh my
gosh you're the fun in my dream lady
I was like
yeah I guess I am and all of a sudden
all the tellers came running around the
manager came they're like oh my God okay
oh my God we have been wondering we all
got the same question y'all know what
the question is right
what's your dream
I was like um
I'm not sure
but I know that it includes inspiring
people
having people believe in themselves
again
teaching them how to get back up when
they've been knocked down
having to be willing to give themselves
a thousand Second Chances
and every time they get to 9.99 press
reset
I'm not sure what it's going to look
like but it's just going to help people
I said I came to check my balance I've
been writing a few checks to you guys to
say yes you've been writing a lot
I said I just want to check my balance
you don't know your balance I said no I
got this really big stack of summary
bank statements at home because my mama
said money Burns her pockets and I don't
want it to burn my pocket I wanted to
pay for my freedom
I said I just came to see what my
balance was if I had enough to fund my
dream as it gets clear
you wrote it down everyone's excited she
wrote it down turned it around to me
I looked at it I said
oh no my name is Lisa Shantae Nichols
and my social security number I said
that is not my money and I am not taking
that money because you're probably gonna
want it back
so just fix that error right now
and they looked at me
I said you really don't think that's
yours
I said no my family's never had five
thousand dollars in the bank
or ten thousand dollars in the bank
that's
sixty two thousand five hundred dollars
in the bank
they said Miss Nichols and everyone
teared up the manager teared up the
tellers teared up
they said Miss Nichols whatever your
dream is
I think you can fund it now
I looked at my son Jelani whom that was
five or six and I said Jelani
our lives are going to be a little
different now baby
Jelani said yeah
Mommy can we
can't we now go to McDonald's
see for three years I've been telling
Jelani I'll make you a Big Mac
Mama makes Big Macs better than
McDonald's
and so it began with a hundred and ten
dollar check
so I don't know what yours is I don't
know what your radical looks like
for some of you your radical was coming
here
right yes yes and this is the beginning
this is the beginning of your radical
this is the this is the bet the next
best step this is the first step and so
I just stopped by to let you know you're
on the right path
and as you ramp up as you ramp up you're
going to have questions you're going to
be afraid I do more things afraid now
than I do Fearless
because the bigger you play the bigger
your breakdowns
every single one of my errors in the
last five years have cost me six figures
like every single one every single one
of my errors has required me to call an
attorney
like they're just big because I'm
playing big
I'm playing big so be willing to go to
the edge
and this is where you are here
be willing
to go to the edge
and not just lean over
and feel the breeze
and watch the people jump
and watch them soar and look through the
windows at all the people who are living
great life don't just go to the edge and
feel it
be willing to lean
fill your heartbeat
feel it
that lets you know you're alive
to let you know you're okay
fear fuels you fear lets you know go get
more information fear lets you know step
a little later and study fear lets you
know get up a little earlier fear let
you know ask for help fear is informing
you it's not stopping you it's just
another emotion like love and compassion
and gratitude we just made it paralyze
us
see fear doesn't stop me fear informs me
and when you get intimately connected
with the fear I feel it and I'm moving
forward anyway I feel it and I'm gonna
love anyway I feel it and I'm going to
invest in me anyway I feel it and I'm
going to show up and play anyway when
you get connected with fear it becomes
your best friend and when you stand on
the edge
you feel the breeze
you feel the fear
and you leap anyway your personality
literally ad is made up of how you think
how you act and how you feel
and how you think how you act and how
you feel is your personality and your
personality is intimately connected to
your personal reality your life so then
if you want to change your life your
personal reality you got to change your
personality and here we go again you got
to start becoming conscious of your
unconscious thoughts you got to start
noticing how you act how you speak you
got to pay attention to how you're
feeling some people would live in guilt
their whole entire life and don't even
know it's guilt because at least it
feels like them so then when you start
doing that you begin to objectify your
subjective self so so then
when you begin to make small changes
back the thought a new thought should
lead to a new Choice a new Choice should
lead to a new Behavior a new Behavior
should create a new experience and a new
experience should create a new emotion
yes and that new emotion is teaching
your body chemically to understand what
your mind is intellectually understood
now your body is embodying the truth
right so then the new emotion should
Inspire new thoughts and that's called
Evolution so how do we get stuck it's
really simple
the stronger the emotion you feel from
some event in your life be it a betrayal
or a trauma or whatever yes the more
altered you feel inside of you the more
you pay attention to the cause outside
of you so the brain takes a snapshot it
freezes an image and embosses that
pattern neurologically in the brain
that's called a memory so we create
long-term memories from strong emotional
events okay so is that true that I just
want to understand the maybe the larger
the event in terms of its emotion too
the stronger of a hold it has over you
yeah well the more it's embossed in your
biology so some certain people have a
strong experience in their life and it
catches all of the brain's attention so
now they think neurologically within the
circuits of the past experience and they
feel chemically within the boundaries of
those emotions and so how you think and
how you feel creates a state of being
now here's the problem
that if you don't know how to mediate or
control your emotional reaction to that
event and you keep that refractory
period of chemicals going on extended
periods of time so that the event
produces a chemical change and the body
needs to return back to homeostasis or
balance but if it can't then the
elongation of that emotional reaction
for weeks say for days or weeks is
called the mood so you say Ed what's
wrong with you I'm in the mood why are
you in a mood well this thing happened
to me five days ago and I'm having one
long emotional reaction so then what you
do is you keep telling the story about
it keep firing and wiring the same
circuits and you keep conditioning the
body into the past so then you wake up
in the morning you look for the emotion
so then now all of a sudden you keep it
lingering for for for weeks or months
that's called the temperament well why
is he so angry I don't know let's ask
him why are you so angry well this thing
happened to me eight months ago I'm
having one long emotional reaction I'm
memorizing my emotions you keep it going
on for years on end that's called a
personality trait so then a person then
is memorizing themselves by living in
the past and so then you say to them
well tell me the story now the latest
research on memory says that 50 percent
of what we talk about in our past isn't
even the truth so we make stuff up about
the past in other words people are
reliving a life that they didn't even
have just to reaffirm that they can't
change right wow so then what's the
significance of this where you place
your attention is where you place your
energy period yes so then the stronger
the emotion that you have the some
problem or condition or person in your
life the more you're paying attention to
them so they captured your attention so
you're giving your power hour away to
that person right because they're
capturing your attention so then there's
an energetic connection to every person
everything everything in your past
present reality has your energy
connected to it so now this is the
significance when a person really
decides to be defined by a vision of the
future instead of the memory of the past
the hardest part about it is all of a
sudden becoming conscious and not making
the same unconscious choice so then
if you lower the volume to your
frustration to your hatred to your anger
if you truly knew how to do that if you
lower the volume to that emotion you
would take your attention off that
person which means you would begin to
break those energetic bonds and now
you're taking your power back yes you're
calling energy back to you and we've
measured this and all of a sudden it
builds this bigger electro magnetic
field around the person's body that's
energy to heal that's energy to create a
new future with right and then if you
didn't want to lower the volume to the
emotion then just take your attention
off the person and every time you take
your attention off the person if you
became conscious of that you wouldn't
feel the emotion now the body though has
been addicted to that emotion because
you're using that person to reaffirm
your addiction to hatred or frustration
and if that person died you'd find
another one so then here you go now so
now you're in a position now where you
begin to lower the volume to that
emotion and the body's going wait a
second you've been you've been doing
this for the last 20 years and all of a
sudden you're just going to stop hating
and the body says well I've been
conditioned this way and conditioning is
based on the past so when the body feels
the the lack of that emotion just like a
drug addict it says hey you're off
schedule here so now the body starts
influencing the mind to think about
experiences that are embossed in the
brain that are based on that emotion so
the emotion now is causing you to think
in the past if we teach a person then
how to trade that frustration or that
hatred for an elevated emotion and
they'll say yeah but you know it was my
ex's fault or I got betrayed by my
partner in business yeah yeah we know
that okay so let's take your partner in
business or take your ex let's duct tape
them put them in a cannon and shoot them
to the moon now what are you gonna do
sooner or later you got to reckon with
yourself and change right so then
teach a person then how to trade that
emotion for an elevated emotion now
trade the emotion for an elevated
emotion right so you're going to give
that up and you're going to practice
feeling gratitude for as an example yes
the person says well I can't feel
gratitude and I say absolutely you can
because you don't practice feeling it
you practice spending most of your time
feeling hatred and frustration so now
it's going to take a little time to
cause that heart of you to bloom or
you're part of yours to bloom once
they're able to feel even the smallest
measure of gratitude where they start
feeling appreciation thankfulness
gratitude its emotional signature when
you when you get something when you're
receiving something
when something has happened to you
uh or when something is happening to you
you say thank you because you're
receiving something so the emotional
signature
of gratitude means the event has already
happened or it's happening to you so the
moment you open your heart and you feel
gratitude well that emotion then is
telling the body that the experience has
already occurred and the thought then
can make it into the body because it's
consistent with the thought so now
you're beginning to program the
autonomic nervous system into a very
specific Destiny you got to maintain
that modified State of Mind and Body
your entire day independent of the
conditions in your outer environment
independent of your body's Cravings of
those emotions and habituations and
independent from time and if you can get
ready because something weird or unusual
some synchronicity some coincidence some
opportunity is going to land in your lap
and you didn't have to go and get it yes
it came to you now you're the vortex of
creation so if you say to me well I was
feeling gratitude but then there was
traffic where my co-worker sent me a
nasty email that I would say oh my God
God you mean you're allowing your
environment your outer environment to
control how you feel and think you're
back to the unconscious program that
you're the victim to your life you got
it but when you start producing those
outcomes in your life you're going to
pay attention to what you did inside of
you and you're going to believe more
that you're the creator of your life and
less of the victim of your life burnout
is real
doing the thing that they actually love
doing it's not just about being busy and
keeping your mind occupied all day you
can be busy and hate your life and get
burnt out if I was an accountant I would
hate my life and burn out in a day
because I don't like being an accountant
but doing this thing that I love I put
in way more effort way more work and I
love it it's been 10 plus years of still
having my YouTube channel and I'm not
burnt out if anything I'm pushing harder
than ever before because I love it and
so I think it's not just about being
busy it's about being busy on the thing
that is your mission for life now
compassion fatigue is a thing doing it
so much that you burn out yourself is
possible but again that is not why most
people are burning out most people I
believe are burning out because they're
spending too much time too much energy
too much effort doing things that they
hate and if you wake up and hate your
life and hate the job you're about to go
to then there's no wonder why you feel
like you're burning out so I recently
came back from going to Tony Robbins
event in Dallas he invited me to sit in
the front row and uh super blessed and
grateful to have Tony support and I went
there with Alex friend of the channel
who helps me run trying to dance salsa
and we're on a super crunch timeline
because Alex was teaching classes the
the evening before we left and then the
day of the last event and we we rushed
down there Alex was flying in just to
get to the event he's late on the first
day we're rushing to leave on the last
day and it's non-stop if you if you've
been to a Tony Robbins event it's it's
all day all night it's eight in the
morning to midnight and then up again
the next day and doing the same thing
and and it's wild and it's fun it's
amazing and my favorite thing to do
whenever I travel is actually meet
believe Nation meet you guys and so all
through the event I wear my believe
hoodie and I'm not wearing Grand stuff
I'm wearing Evan Carmichael stuff with
the plane and the believe on the back
and people are stopping me and that's
actually the best it doesn't take away
from my experience Tony's often on stage
at the top at the beginning of every
event saying hey I have some friends of
mine you might know them don't be
celebrities leave them alone don't talk
to them let them have their own
experience and it always makes me sad
when he says that because for me meeting
you guys meeting people who recognize me
and that's a group that I over index
because people who watch Tony videos you
know they're probably going to find my
content I like it I like it more when
people come and say hi it adds to the
experience for me and then on the last
day before we rushed out to go to the
airport I set up a Meetup right I had an
hour open before having to get to the
airport so let's do a meet up let's do a
local Dallas Richardson Texas Meetup
right and and it could have spent the
time doing something else or sleeping in
or writing my book or doing anything
else but
it's not burnout for me like that fuels
me that gives me more energy I love it
hanging out with believe Nation gives me
more energy than it takes away and I
then took an Uber to get to my to the
airport and the guy who drove the Uber
was actually in the the Meetup in
Richardson's like I gotta leave early
because I got to start my job okay great
and then I book an Uber and there he is
the total fluke but amazing and so it's
a lot of work you know I was all day all
night not connecting with my team not
doing the things that I'm supposed to be
doing and I still make time to be with
people and and make a one-hour Meetup
because that hour was open and
it fuels me but if it was something that
I hated just that half an hour just 15
minutes I'd start to feel like I'm
burning out like I don't want to be here
this is terrible and so I think it's
really important that you're doing work
that you love that would be a burnout
for other people but not a burnout for
you because you love it so much so how
do you find it how do you find the work
that you love I got a three-step process
called who I how I'm going to talk about
it in depth in my next book but let's do
a super quick analysis here to help you
guys who might be struggling step number
one is who so you're who is your most
important core value what is your most
important core value as a human being
mine is believe it's a one word most
important core value for me so when you
figure out what it is that you stand for
as a human you can then look at your
life and see where you're falling short
if you are unhappy with life it's
because you are living incongruently
with your most important core value so
someone whose core value is freedom as
an example
you can look at your life like are you
allowed to be free are you free at work
are you free in your relationships are
you free you know in these different
areas if not then you're not going to be
happy that's why you're not happy
because your boss doesn't allow you to
have freedom mine is believe so believe
has to be in everything that I touch if
there's a situation that's lacking
believe I'm not going to be happy with
it so that just gives you already an
indication of who you are and starts to
make sense of your life going backwards
and allows you to plan it better going
forward so it's one of the most
important exercises I think anybody can
do figure out what your who is who I
have step two is why so why is your
purpose your purpose comes in your pain
your purpose comes from the deepest
darkest most painful moment in your life
whatever that was your purpose is to
help other people who are currently
going through that thing whatever you
struggled with suffered with endured
felt like you never want to wish that on
your worst enemy never want to go back
and experience again that pain that's
what I'm talking about you want to help
other people who are currently going
through that pain because there's a lot
of people who are currently going
through that thing who you were X number
of years ago there's a lot of people who
are currently like that right now that's
who you want to help for Life that'll
never get old that's your purpose for
life I want to help entrepreneurs for
life I believe in entrepreneurs for life
because I struggled so much as an
entrepreneur and I want to make the path
a little bit easier for everybody else
so that's your wire and your who and
your why are constant they never change
your core values and your purpose are
for life and that's amazing the last
step is how who I how how is your
passion how is how you got out of the
pain that you're in so you struggled
with something how did you get out of it
you may not be fully out of it maybe
you're still on your journey out of it
but you're further ahead than you used
to be how did you get out of it did you
read books did you watch videos did you
meditate did you walk your dogs did you
listen to music like how did you get out
of it how did you get out of it and that
is a recipe that you can teach other
people how you got out of it was not
some random one-off situation you can
teach other people so I struggled a lot
with my business I felt worthless as a
human I wanted to quit I told my partner
that I quit how I got out of it was
model and success I looked at Bill Gates
how he started Microsoft and I applied
those strategies to my business and we
started to see some success 20 years
later what am I doing still modeling
success right I want to learn from Grant
I want to learn from Steve I want to
learn from Kanye I want to learn from
these people it's why keep creating this
content how I got out of it was studying
success and now I teach other people how
to study success
right how you actually go about doing it
may change when I first started doing it
20 years ago is through books right now
it's through videos and in 10 years 20
years is going to be through VR and a
bunch of other technologies that I'm
sure are coming but
the how you got out is a teachable
recipe that you can give to other people
so if you're struggling with burnout
and you think it's because you don't
love the work that you're doing and you
know that you're destined for something
greater that you do have Michael Jordan
level Talent at something but you don't
know what it is and you want to figure
it out figure it out this is this is the
process this is the easiest process I
know of to get there figure out your who
your one where most important core value
figure out your why your purpose comes
to your pain and figure out your how
which is your passion how you got out of
it you can teach other people and that
will set you up for an amazing life with
hopefully very little burnout and
definitely a lot of purpose
because you made it this far in a video
I want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
Nation you made it here all the way to
the end and I love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome to learn
the seven habits to beat procrastination
check the video right there next to me I
think you'll love it continue to believe
and I'll see you there I want you to
stop dreaming and I want you to just
start doing small things I want you to
go back to curiosity and less into
crushing your big goals the thing about
life and business